[Music]
in assisted resignation news Oh sounds
forced over you're fired
sounds like somebody helps you to die
die
it sounds like what's that what's the
popular thing now they say a radical
something now is like radical this
radical there yeah it's like radical
tubular dude my graddic radical Islam
like radical leftist group or a radical
radicals the word now or some [ __ ] like
that
I remember when radical was dope like
that's radical did righteous radical
submitted by Billie Jean rest in peace
mine is his birthday
yesterday was it yeah he would have been
sixty damn man that's crazy he still had
the skin of a three-year-old yeah this
company will quit your job for you
what a pussy-ass thing what why people
are really trying to avoid confrontation
that much yeah that's [ __ ] why easy
it's not that hard to quit a job dude
hey man just got shot I quit it's pretty
simple oh why are you quitting I'm not
okay about it Bart right about the
confrontation thing it's about
confrontation yeah that's a big part of
it oh [ __ ] my mind went somewhere else
man
where'd it go where'd he go I thought it
was like the opposite where like people
aren't good with words so they'll say
stupid [ __ ] when they quit and then
they'll ruin relationships I mean
they're that is avoiding the
confrontation though you're avoiding the
confrontation of having to go through
that process oh I thought it was like
avoiding being a stupid ass versus
avoiding because you're scared but
you're a stupid ass because you're
scared right no I'm not like like like
scared because you're nervous of the
confrontation you end up saying
something dumb like what you think
that's another one I remember those days
man what is like when I used to be
apprehensive about confrontation like
when I was really young yeah I don't
feel that anymore
I mean I I mean I feel weird sometimes
you know but I don't feel like this is
bottom anymore I mean I feel like that
anxiety that you feel it's pretty normal
yeah I don't know
anyone that goes into like a
confrontation it's like [ __ ] this is
easy like me only my yeah yeah yeah but
I think it's also basic human skills
that you should have to be able to talk
to people you don't have to be able to
like [ __ ] someone up but being able to
talk about how you feel in an open space
or like hey I don't want this job
anymore like that should be a basic
human story people are the best at
trying to be non confrontational so
though try not to be confrontational but
they'll just talk a bunch of [ __ ] behind
your [ __ ] back it's the water look it
like they'll look dead into the windows
of your soul and they'll just be like hi
this is so long I've missed you in the
right when you're right it's like what
the [ __ ] it's not you it's me
okay yeah second model that's like a
Korean specialty so [ __ ] annoying
yeah I've always hated conversation my
health I mean in too deep but as I've
been getting older I never saw creating
a job as confrontational like that's
like we're supposed to be with like
breaking up with someone oh really
I see like work can be like if you have
differences at work and you don't like
somebody I think that's confrontational
when you got to talk to them and like
solve some [ __ ] out and tell them like
what you don't like about them and then
but when it when it was quitting I
always saw it as like okay bye-bye
you're awesome well let me give you
these okay bye I think any time you have
to be like straight up and up front with
someone it's considered confrontational
so even if you're like like they hire
you to do something or like hey I don't
want to do this job anymore I think for
most people they probably as
confrontational or does he have to be
like yeah like I guess uncomfortable and
straight up to talk about it be
agreeable it's gonna be some sort of I
think is for you like what did it
happened I'm with Joe where it was like
this [ __ ] is holding me back from what I
really want to do so it's more of like
okay cool like I need to get out of this
[ __ ] up oh into Duke a lot of people
they they feel bad of like but how are
they gonna feel and I gotta let this
person down and then they start thinking
oh that means if I leave they gotta find
someone to film us yeah I just gave this
person extra work or you know all that
yeah
that plus the at least for me it's plus
the added like concern of down like
what's what are they gonna think about
me now after [ __ ] you want about me
[ __ ] I don't [ __ ] it because like
especially if it's a job and you're
freaking up with that job and then
you're trying to get a new job and then
they call your old job for if I did a
great job at what I did you don't put
that mother [ __ ] down for references
yeah put someone else to - yeah well I
thought you talking about like so like
one day with a hassle how come a foot
kill yourself male foot alright this
company here called exit and beg like EG
g dali tightly be your [ __ ] company
gonna change I heard your use of my eggs
not do you not at all we help people
quit their [ __ ] job
read that right welcome to my restaurant
[ __ ] Ricky's auto repair bucket smog
check it's a hot dog story so you know
like when you enter a play something you
exit it that kind of so it's a sunny
China Japan you know you don't quit jobs
in Japan you know well because you in
the corner they literally just put you
in a corner if you [ __ ] up and then they
just let you sit there for the rest of
your career there yeah so they're saying
in this article like in Japan it's known
like the work culture it's around the
idea that people spend the rest of their
lives in one company you're loyalist
right because out here you know it's
like oh you have a great resume you have
so much work experience out there they
see you as a two-timing [ __ ] you're
like I see you going to [ __ ] Sony and
[ __ ] in jindo I see you you little
[ __ ] [ __ ] promiscuous employee yeah
it's working everywhere
I kind of see it like that too like my
resume stack I'm like why you shouldn't
be working it's in the [ __ ] place
every year you have you have no ability
to commit to anybody huh that's that's
that's how they see it as especially if
it's like limp like six months a year
yeah I look at that and I'm like oh [ __ ]
I don't give a [ __ ] about your
experience I don't want to I don't want
you here for you since you're not very
confrontational I have gone better and
now I mean you know I feel like she's
come frame your ass right now yeah
when's the last time you had like a
confrontation that you've dealt well
like you dealt with it pretty well I
don't know I guess recently I had one
with you with people all right
you ever grab someone by the shirt and
go like this I never do them no never
like this shirt yeah I'm of comfort to
you like I don't I don't shy away from
it but I've yet to even be this close to
going like there's well there's this
dude at my old unit I thought we had a
connection cuz it's Peruvian and I'm
like 1/8 Peruvian I guess when I first
came in I was like dogs proved in his
dog how many times c2 Peruvian Marines
even they probably thought I was a
[ __ ] Chino and then you came up to my
right Peruvian knowing that this boy he
was five years in it was the e3 which is
Lance Corporal Mike how the [ __ ] are you
which is like a like a low rank at the
beginning right my house is falling for
five years and he's still eat three yeah
he sucks three years later I got
promoted twice above him and I still
feel bad cuz he's been around for a long
time she has a lot of a tenure but not
seniority and then this is one time
where he was just like holding back for
our entire unit or not our unit our
section and then my boss was like yellow
can you talk to them and then this is
like back in the old Marine Corps day
Sonic all right so I'm like uh hosting
O'Gill
oh they go so girl like I talk to you
over here it was yeah so we walk around
the corner and the minute he walked
around the corner I did though I put
them against the wall cause I know if
you don't shape up and if you keep
making our section look I'm gonna [ __ ]
your ass up
he's like oh [ __ ] my back that's the
most good thing ever good
that's one hug people do they always do
this yeah you were in the ghetto and
somebody says that's you just run
they're not trying to talk at all
they're gonna [ __ ] whoop your ass
dude my man okay let me talk to you real
quick sir I saw you do your little
prayer hands I know what this be you
gotta be polite about your nose watching
yeah and when you go around the corner
sorry girl go there to work a little
harder Papa doesn't work that way I like
his method doc is it it's like a did he
shape up right away oh yeah I mean it's
been like it's like there has been
numerous write-ups from other other my
bosses and I just got promoted to his
position like there's been numerous
writers oh yeah that makes sense
I was like that's the first thing you
did I was like wow that's been like oh
you know what's so embarrassing - even
though you guys went around the corner
everybody knows that you did that to him
because you scratch - oh right it's just
like this little rose on his shirt no
they already know what happened cuz just
a little rosette it comes out it comes
out like yeah yo Gil what happened do
you believe it's just all twisted up
right here is a belly button show a
shirt but yes this Caribbean brother
they're saying that they will quit your
job for you for far for four hundred and
fifty dollar damn Dan that's genius
and then repeat clients will get a night
routine client dollar discount there
yeah so what they're saying now is that
it's getting more and more common to
have people leave their jobs in Japan
yeah especially since the unemployment
rate is below two point five percent for
this year so it's really easy for people
to find jobs and so that's right now
they're just finding it and even easier
to leave those jobs if they have if they
hire this company where they don't have
to deal with the confrontation the
awkwardness and and yeah so they're
saying that usually you need about two
weeks notice but then these people
because they don't want to deal with the
petition in the awkwardness they're just
using up their sick days or the holidays
or whatever for those two weeks and then
they just take off I I would give like a
month notice that's actually like the
etiquette workplace etiquette guidelines
laid out by this company named Savi
Tokyo a big base they say a month they
say it should be about a month it should
also have a formal letter of resonate
resignation nothing also cut off a part
of the picture you know give out small
gifts to your co-workers I go yeah
that's pretty cool that's really a
graceful way to leave that is it's kind
of like the company yeah that's like
thanks for helping me out yeah and
recognizing all the favors you know I
gave money to some of my co-workers for
my last paycheck I broke them off like a
couple hundred bucks for people that
kind of stuck their neck out for me and
stuff and then yeah I mean I thought
that was standard at least that's what
my parents kind of taught me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]